pourquoi on t'entends moi la radio en ce
moment
parce que parce que les gens ils aiment
pas trop méchants sont en ce moment
alors Vanessa Paradis vous êtes devenus
une mère très très attentive vous êtes
ordonné maintenant avant vous faites les
valises quand vous partez en vous partez
en vacances et tout vachement sérieux
donc on fait une interview très sérieuse
et c'est l'interview expliqué à ma fille
oh la bouche pas pendant le jingle
[Musique]
votre fille vous demande maman pourquoi
on meurt pourquoi on meurt parce
dans l'histoire et un début au milieu et
une fin et puis il faut bien que ça
s'arrête au bout d'un moment on devient
complètement à ramasser à la cuillère
mais après il y a autre chose surtout je
lui dire ça ça sert à quoi de travailler
puisqu'il suffit d'aller à la machine
pour prendre de l'argent
mon père il dit c'est le taxi de la
liberté l'argent moi j'aime bien cette
expression
maman c'est quoi ce que vous mettez dans
vos cigarettes avec papa
de toute façon moi c'est du tabac donc
ça va il y a pas de problème non mais de
toute façon je lui expliquerai je
préfère ah oui je préfère
[Rires]
il est arrivé la même chose que vous
emmerdez-vous
[Rires]
pourquoi papa il a fait un baiser sur la
bouche et la baby-sitter
parce que il aime bien qu'il voulait lui
dire bonjour puis après je vais tout de
suite
on peut quand même par un bisou quoi
maman pourquoi on t'entend moi la radio
en ce moment
parce que parce que les gens ils aiment
pas trop méchants sont en ce moment et
dit maman quelle est la question qui n'a
pas de réponse
c'est chiant les gosses
pourquoi pourquoi je t'aime et pas de
réponse c'est comme ça quoi
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu